une alternative est vraiment meilleure que l'autre,
mais nous sommes trop stupides pour savoir laquelle,
et comme nous ne savons pas laquelle, nous aurions dû juste
prendre l'option la moins risquée.
Même en mettant deux alternatives côte à côte,
avec toutes les informations, un choix reste toujours difficile.
Les choix difficiles sont difficiles,
non pas à cause de nous ni de notre ignorance ;
ils sont difficiles car il n'existe pas d'option idéale.
Mais s'il n'y a pas de meilleure option,
si la balance ne penche pas vers une alternative
ou l'autre,
alors, les alternatives doivent certainement être de valeur égale.
Peut-être que ce qu'il faut se dire avec les choix difficiles,
c'est qu'ils se résument à deux bonnes options équivalentes.
Mais ça ne peut pas être ça.
Si les alternatives sont toutes aussi bonnes les unes que les autres,
on devrait tirer à pile ou face pour les départager,
et c'est peut-être une erreur de penser
que c'est la manière de choisir une carrière,
un lieu d'habitation ou une personne à épouser : tirer à pile ou face.
Il y a une autre raison de penser
que les choix difficiles ne sont pas des choix
parmi des options tout aussi bonnes les unes que les autres.
Supposons qu'on a le choix entre deux métiers :
vous pourriez être un banquier d'affaires
ou un peintre.
Il y a pas mal de facteurs qui comptent dans un choix comme celui-ci,
comme l'intérêt pour le travail,
bénéficier d'une sécurité financière,
avoir le temps pour une famille, et ainsi de suite.
Peut-être que la carrière d'artiste vous ferait découvrir
de nouvelles formes
d'expressions graphiques.
Peut-être que la carrière de banquier
vous ferait découvrir
de nouvelles formes de manipulations financières.
Imaginez ces deux emplois que vous aimez
de façon à ce qu'aucun des deux ne soit mieux que l'autre.
Maintenant, imaginez que nous en améliorons un légèrement.
Supposez que la banque, qui vous courtise,
ajoute 500 dollars par mois à votre salaire.
L'argent supplémentaire rend-il l'emploi de banquier
plus attrayant que celui d'artiste ?
Pas forcément.
Un salaire plus élevé rend ce poste de banquier
meilleur qu'avant,
mais ce n'est peut-être pas suffisant pour rendre
le fait d'être banquier plus attrayant que d'être artiste.
Mais si une amélioration dans l'un des postes
ne le rend pas meilleur que l'autre,
alors les deux postes initiaux
ne peuvent pas avoir été équivalents.
Si vous débutez avec deux éléments aussi bons l'un que l'autre,
et que vous en améliorez un des deux,
il doit alors être mieux que l'autre.
Ce n'est pas le cas avec les alternatives dans le cas des choix difficiles.
Nous avons maintenant un casse-tête.
Nous avons deux emplois.
Aucun n'est mieux que l'autre,
mais ils ne sont pas équivalents.
Alors comment sommes-nous censés choisir ?
Quelque chose semble s'être mal passé ici.
Peut-être le choix lui-même est problématique
et la comparaison impossible.
Mais ce ne peut pas être vrai.
Ce n'est pas comme si nous essayons de choisir entre
deux éléments qui ne pouvent pas être comparés.
Nous sommes en train de peser la valeur de deux emplois, après tout,
pas la valeur du nombre neuf
par rapport à celle d'un œuf au plat.
Une comparaison de l’intérêt respectif de deux emplois
est quelque chose que l'on peut faire,
une chose que l'on fait souvent.
Je pense que le problème survient
à cause d'une hypothèse inconsciente
que nous faisons à propos de la valeur.
Nous pensons inconsciemment que les valeurs
comme la justice, la beauté, la gentillesse,
sont semblables à des quantités scientifiques,
comme la longueur, la masse ou le poids.
Prenez n'importe quelle question qui n'implique pas de valeurs,
comme savoir laquelle de deux valises est la plus lourde.
Il n'y a que trois possibilités.
Le poids d'une valise est supérieur, inférieur,
ou égal à celui de l'autre valise.
Les propriétés comme le poids peuvent être représentées
par des nombres réels -- un, deux, trois, et ainsi de suite --
et il n'y a que trois comparaisons possibles
entre deux nombres réels quels qu'ils soient.
Un nombre est plus grand, moins grand,
ou égal à l'autre.
Ce n'est pas le cas pour les valeurs.
En tant que créatures héritières de l'esprit des Lumières,
nous avons tendance à penser
que la réflexion scientifique est la clé
de tout ce qui est important dans notre monde,
mais le monde des valeurs
est différent du monde de la science.
Les éléments d'un de ces mondes
peuvent être quantifiés par des nombre réels,
pas les éléments de l'autre.
Nous ne devrions pas partir du principe que
le monde du certain, des longueurs et des poids,
a la même structure que le monde du ressenti,
de ce que nous devrions faire.
Donc si ce qui compte pour nous --
la joie d'un enfant, l'amour que vous portez à votre conjoint --
ne peut pas être représenté par de vrais nombres,
alors il n'y a aucune raison de penser
qu'en matière de choix, il n'y a que trois possibilités --
cette alternative est meilleure, pire ou équivalente
à l'autre.
Il nous faut intégrer une nouvelle, une quatrième relation
au delà du bien, moins bien ou équivalent,
qui décrive ce qui se passe lors de choix difficiles.
J'aime dire que les alternatives sont
« sur un pied d'égalité ».
Quand les alternatives sont sur un pied d'égalité,
votre choix peut être très important,
mais aucune alternative n'est meilleure que l'autre.
Les alternatives sont plutôt
sur le même niveau de valeur,
dans la même ligue de valeurs,
bien qu'elles soient en même temps très différentes
en termes de type de valeur.
C'est pourquoi le choix est difficile.
Comprendre les choix difficiles de cette façon
révèle quelque chose sur nous que nous ne connaissions pas.
Chacun de nous a le pouvoir
de créer des raisons.
Imaginez un monde dans lequel chaque choix que vous devez faire
est un choix simple,
ainsi, il y aura toujours une solution idéale.
S'il y a une option idéale,
c'est celle que vous devriez choisir,
parce qu'être rationnel,
c'est choisir ce qui est le mieux plutôt que le pire,
choisir ce que vous avez le plus de raisons de choisir.
Dans un monde comme celui-ci,
nous aurions toutes les raisons
de porter des chaussettes noires plutôt que des chaussettes roses,
de manger des céréales plutôt que des beignets,
de vivre dans une ville plutôt qu'à la campagne,
d'épouser Betty à la place de Lolita.
Un monde rempli uniquement de choix simples
nous enchaînerait à la raison.
Quand on y pense,
c'est dingue de croire
que les raisons qu'on nous a données
ont décidé qu'il était logique de pratiquer
le passe-temps que vous pratiquez,
de vivre dans la maison dans laquelle vous vivez,
de faire le métier que vous faites.
Mais vous avez plutôt fait face à des alternatives
équivalentes -- des choix difficiles--
et vous avez décidé vous-même des raisons
de choisir ce passe-temps, cette maison et cet emploi.
Quand les alternatives sont équivalentes,
les raisons qui nous sont données,
celles qui déterminent si nous faisons une erreur ou pas,
ne disent rien de ce que l'on doit faire.
C'est là, au moment où se font les choix difficiles,
que nous devons utiliser
notre pouvoir normatif,
le pouvoir de créer ses propres raisons,
de devenir
le genre de personne
qui préfère vivre à la campagne
plutôt qu'en ville.
Quand l'on décide entre
des options équivalentes,
nous pouvons faire quelque chose de vraiment remarquable.
Nous pouvons nous ranger corps et âme derrière une option.
C'est cela que je choisis.
C'est qui je suis. Je suis faite pour la banque.
Je choisis les beignets au chocolat.
Cette réponse aux choix difficiles
est une réponse rationnelle,
mais elle n'est pas dictée par des raisons qu'on nous a données.
Par contre, c'est justifié par des raisons que nous avons créées nous-mêmes.
Quand nous créons nos propres raisons
afin de devenir tel type de personne plutôt qu'un autre,
nous devenons de tout notre cœur la personne que nous sommes.
On pourrait dire que nous devenons les auteurs
de notre propre vie.
Alors quand on fait face à des choix difficiles,
on ne devrait pas se frapper la tête contre les murs
en essayant de savoir quelle alternative est la meilleure.
Il n'y a pas de meilleur choix.
Au lieu de chercher des raisons n'importe où,
nous devrions chercher les raisons ici :
qui est-ce que je veux être ?
Vous pouvez décider de porter des chaussettes roses,
d'aimer les céréales, d'être un banquier qui vit à la campagne,
et je peux décider de porter des chaussettes noires,
d'être citadine et d'être une artiste qui aime les beignets.
Ce que nous faisons à travers les choix difficiles
dépend vraiment de chacun de nous.
Alors, les gens qui n'utilisent pas leur pouvoir normatif dans les choix difficiles
sont des vagabonds.
Nous connaissons tous des gens comme cela.
Je me suis laissée embarquer dans une carrière d'avocate.
Je n'ai pas commis mon agence.
Je n'étais pas faite pour cela.
Les personnes qui se laissent porter, laissent le monde
écrire l'histoire de leur vie.
Ils laissent les mécanismes de récompense et punition --
tapes sur la tête, la peur, la facilité d'une alternative --
déterminer ce qu'ils font.
Alors la leçon en matière de choix difficiles :
réfléchissez à comment vous souhaitez vivre,
à ce que vous pouvez faire,
et au travers des choix difficiles,
devenez cette personne.
Loin d'être une source d'effroi et d'agonie,
les choix difficiles sont de précieuses opportunités
pour nous de célébrer ce qui est spécial
à la condition humaine,
que les raisons qui dictent nos choix
soient correctes ou non,
manquent parfois,
et c'est là, au moment de faire des choix difficiles,
que nous avons le pouvoir
de créer nos propres raisons,
de devenir la personne unique que nous sommes.
Et c'est pourquoi les choix difficiles ne sont pas une malédiction
mais au contraire une bénédiction.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)